[Music]
we're celebrating Valentine's Day with a
little help from our furry feathered
friends here are 20 cute animals getting
married showing us what real love is
stick until the end to see two turtles
fully in love if you love cute animals
as much as we do be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on our videos and
click on the like button if you enjoyed
this video
llama love we're going to call these two
Mildred and Steve it looks like they
couldn't be more thrilled but their big
day has finally arrived if you look
closely you can see the excitement on
their faces or is that just what llamas
look like all the time say cheese happy
couple best laid plans of squirrels and
Men okay this one is just downright
hilarious
a squirrel groom with cold feet and his
blushing bride at least we think she is
blushing hard to tell what's happening
under all that fur but just look at her
she's so hopeful and full of love he'd
be nuts to leave her at the altar
geriatric matrimony it looks like these
two basset hounds let's call them Ethel
and Merv found each other in the
twilight of their lives we're not 100%
sure but Merv may have had a bad too
much champagne can somebody give Ethel
back her glasses like she can't see a
thing
bunny bond in this elegant bunny wedding
the bride seems to have a bit of stage
fright is she afraid of the camera or
her wedding night it's understandable
because the groom seems to have missed
his mark when he was told to kiss the
bride
maybe he's a loud smooch err pucker up
bunny Brides 80s hair band wedding these
two adorable dogs are so 80s you can
almost smell the Aqua Net in the air
teeth their first dance was to a ballad
by journey or Motley Crue this big
haired bride chose a very stable
clean-cut groom you know what they say
opposites attract
we hope it lasts hog heaven what could
be cuter than two pigs declaring their
love for each other while donning a
bowtie and a veil though it does seem
like they are eager to get right to the
buffet this is going to be a wedding the
whole barnyard will talk about for years
'lord beagle and his royal Duchess we
look at this picture and think Roy
wedding these aristocrats are receiving
their public on a red carpet
there are even gourmet doggy treats with
paw prints on them only the fanciest of
canines get to enjoy a wedding so
extravagant are they to be the next
Prince William and Kate penguins either
this penguin wedding party is about to
surprise the bride and groom with a
show-stopping dance to their favorite
boy band track or they forgot which way
to face for the ceremony guys the
weddings that way they're in perfect
formation for a One Direction dance
routine pin it fellas we can't wait for
another Happy Feet movie piggy
sister-wives these pigs have been
watching too much of Big Love is anyone
going to tell them that polygamy is not
legal wait while we're on this subject
is Pig marriage actually legal maybe we
can give them a pass since they're so
adorable the groom sure does look pretty
pleased with himself come on now don't
be such a ham meerkat loved meerkat Suzy
meerkat Sam do the jitterbug out of
meerkat land looks like meerkat love if
muskrats can do it why can't bay
something tells us they don't love
having their wedding photos taken if
they had a thought bubble it would
probably say are you kidding me right
now we promise to tolerate each other we
Majan this marriage proposal started out
with well we're not getting any younger
cats tend to have a healthy bit of
attitude it's a wonder when two of them
can get along we bet they skip the love
honor and cherish vows most likely these
two probably promise to tolerate each
other
rich meerkats problems do hurry minister
Barrington we don't want to miss high
tea yes this is the second meerkat
wedding photo but it's too hilarious
the minister is better get on with it
posthaste we know that Barnaby despises
cold tea and biscuits and Winifred gets
bored so very quickly monkey marriage ah
young monkey love is there anything
better we think this couple will stand
the test of time we can picture them
showing this photo to their
grandchildren some day saying we were so
young men Mazel Tov to the happy couple
may you enjoy many many years of happy
memories joyful Penguins from the looks
of this picture we think these two
lovebirds eloped and ran away together
from the look of joy on their faces we
can tell
found true love did you know penguins
propose to each other by placing a
special stone at their sweethearts feet
so cute
runaway bride goose this bride is
hightailing it out of there just like
Julia Roberts in the movie runaway bride
this goose is spooked easily at the
altar her betrothed is calling after her
but it appears to be too late this
modern Galan's back on the fast track to
singles Ville sorry Charlie
you oh how much you know when you're
about to make a big commitment and
someone reveals a humdinger of a secret
that makes you question the whole
arrangement well that's what we imagine
is going on here
it looks like the bride just told the
groom about her little gambling habit
and subsequent enormous debt we'll keep
each other warm it's important to find a
good cuddle partner when you have no fur
to keep you warm
these hairless cats seem to have found
that in each other they probably vowed
to love each other in fur and boldness
sickness and health Congrats on finding
your cuddle mate Montague and Capulet
two households both alike in dignity in
fair Verona this forbidden love affair
harkens back to the Montagues and
Capulets but will this Romeo and Juliet
be able to beat the odds this time or is
their fate equally sealed
Oh Romeo wherefore art thou we hope this
rebellious couple makes it and lives
their happily ever after turtle love
seeing this picture makes everything
right with the world if you're having a
bad day just look at these two adorable
turtles uniting and holy matrimony we
guarantee you'll smile we're calling
these two Fred and Ginger because well
that's what they look like their wedding
dance must have been to a very slow song
we hope this made your day because it
definitely made ours and that's it for
20 cute animals getting married showing
us what real love is be sure to check
out our other cute animal videos on our
channel happy Valentine's Day